welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and spider-man no way home breaks
the multiverse as savagely as it does
our hearts with so many questions
remaining in the final minutes but
spoiler warning before i continue
because i am about to go deep into this
movie's big twists along with all the
key stuff that happens in the final
minutes of the film seriously spoilers
ahead okay everyone out of the room
great holy [ __ ] i gotta get this off my
chest toby and andrew charlie cox is
matt murdock attorney in law it may
other villains coming through the cracks
in reality who are they and now no one
remembers peter he's got a new suit
eddie brock doesn't wipe and to top off
all of those crazy thoughts deafening my
brain while other bullies outside the
amc were like hey where was mephisto
we got a freaking trailer for doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness i
am gonna break that down but first we
gotta recap what just happened and you
could celebrate spiderman no way home by
checking out our awesome merch at
newrockstarsmerch.com
we have an amazing new limited edition
shirt called strange entanglement as
well as a kingpin inspired long live the
king shirt you can get these both at
newrockstarsmerch.com okay so in
spiderman no way home during dr
strange's spell to make people forget
that peter parker's spider-man but peter
keeps making his various exceptions for
his friend's loved ones and then
everything goes to hell and peter yells
out basically everyone who knew that i
was spider-man before should still know
and that is the key line that provides
the logic by which alternate universe
characters are now warped into this
reality green goblin doc ox sandman the
lizard electro they all knew who
spider-man was but later we learned this
also includes the andrew garfield and
toby maguire variants of peter parker i
knew they were going to be in this movie
but i still can't believe it but we
should say technically speaking people
who knew that peter parker was
spider-man should also include kirsten
dunst mary jane both harry osborns those
people on the train and spider-man 2
captain stacy and a whole bunch of
people at oscorp and the garfield
continuity but i guess those actors
didn't get the coal but we do get to see
tom hardy eddie brock in the first post
credit scene i didn't think that he knew
that peter parker was spider-man before
the warp however the venom symbiote
probably did since he had just been
talking about his symbiote multiversal
hyde mind right before that warp okay so
anyway peter disagrees with doctor
strange that the villains need to be
doomed back to their deaths so he
listens to ant-may and he tries to
redeem and fix these villains however
green goblin betrays him leading to
ant-may's death but not before she
croaks with great power there must also
be great responsibility and there must
also be a slight rewording of the
classic line ned uses strange's sling
ring to open a portal to see peter
parker and just by making that wish he
finds other peters who have warped into
this reality including andrew garfield
spider-man and then toby maguire youth
pastor spider-man the banter among these
two and with peter it's just an amazing
part of the film i'm gonna go into it in
future videos but these three nerds team
up they science the [ __ ] out of it and
one by one they fix their broken toys
and all agree how gross it is that
toby's webbing comes out of his body but
during the battle and statue of liberty
goblin bombs the machina dichotomous box
and that causes the spell to spill out
around liberty island and several
glowing figures appear in the sky
through the cracks it's hard to tell who
but they looked like other spidey
villains like there was definitely one
glowing outline of the rhino i assume
morbius was up there creeping down at us
but then as the battle wages on peter
almost kills goblin on the ruins of
cap's shield by restaging cap's near
beheading of iron man in civil war
almost going full john walker there but
toby peter catches that goblin glider
and gives tom hall and peter a chance to
avoid blood being on his hands instead
they hit osbourne with some anti-serum
so he comes to spider jesus strange
completes the memory wife spell and
everyone glows back home but at the cost
of everyone in this reality forgetting
that peter is spider-man that includes
ned and mj who don't know who peter is
happy hogan doesn't know who he is he
only knows that he knew aunt may through
spider-man jay jonah jameson no longer
knows anyone who found out from
mysterio's broadcast no longer knows
they only know that there's a spider-man
in this universe peter parker is a
nobody however mj still wears peter's
black dahlia necklace and as he visits
her in her donut shop he's just happy
that mj and ned got into mit and that
means that mit vice chancellor likely
already put in a good word for mj and
ned but there must be no record of peter
parker being spider-man being part of
their original rejection existing
anywhere so peter moves into an
apartment that cruelly does not have a
russian landlord screaming give me rent
you'll get your rent when you fix this
damn door and then he swings in a new
suit with brighter blues past the 30
rock ice rink so we'll be sure to keep
an eye out for him in the hawkeye finale
so the first post-credits scene shows
tom hardy eddie brock fresh from his
reality warp into the mcu in the venom
let there be carnage post-credit scene
at a bar in mexico learning all about
how the mcu is filled with superheroes
they talk about iron man and hulk thanos
the blip he plans to go to new york to
talk to spider-man but then he glows and
fades back into his venomverse but he
leaves one little smudge of venom goo
behind and that goo takes one baby step
toward infecting someone in the mcu i'm
wondering if it could be flash thompson
who does become a version of venom in
the comics now again they would have had
to know that peter parker was spider-man
in order to have warped into the mcu to
begin with which is why that one line in
the carnage post-credits scene was so
important 80 billion light years of hive
knowledge across universes would explode
your tiny little brain hive knowledge
across universes and then the warp
happened right after that therefore
among that multiversal hive knowledge
was one universe where venom knew that
peter was spider-man maybe even this
symbiote chunk that's now in the mcu
since multiversal figures were warped in
from various points in time timing a
flat circle but let us now move on to
this trailer for doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness it is creepy as
hell actually forget the simile this
might actually just be hell the trailer
opens on the steps of carmartage as
autumn leaves float past and candles
flicker out we hear dialogue from
earlier no way home wong's debate was
strange over the spell when wong says
it's too dangerous and it's strange
chides peter saying we tampered with the
stability of space-time the multiverse
is a concept about which we know
frighteningly little now interestingly
no way home confirmed that wong now
holds the rank of sorcerer supreme on
the technicality that strange was
blipped for five years an apparent
retcon of the in-game script that listed
wong among the snap victims i guess that
would explain why wang was the one who
presided over the avengers and chongqi
and suggests that strange might be a bit
more vulnerable than we thought then
there's a close-up of strange's broken
watch which in the 2016 doctor strange
film symbolized strange's own unhealable
wound of his hands which initially led
his pursuit of the mystic arts and
something that he eventually let go of
as he put his soul over his body
strange's face is reflected in that
watch's broken face broken glass now
kind of symbolizing a shattered reality
in the mcu and reflecting how this
strange exists in a broken reality
broken from his own actions then we hear
the voice of mordo saying your
desecration of reality will not go
unpunished remember mordo was salty over
the way the ancient one flirted with
dark dimension magic she taught us it
was forbidden
while she drew on its power to steal
centuries of life she did what she
thought was right the bill comes to you
and anger that he carried on into the
post-credits scene too many sorcerers
then strange goes through a snowy gate
to realize the gothic steeple of a
skyscraper is detached from its building
as various other buildings seem to melt
up into the sky the visuals actually
look like live action versions of what
we saw in what if episode 4 when that
universe's doctor strange tried to
bypass an absolute point in time and
caused all of reality to melt into inky
nothingness something similar may have
happened in the live-action mcu perhaps
doctor strange's initial spell in the
way it caused the multiversal anomalies
or maybe in the way they fixed that
crisis by sending home redeemed villains
and therefore altering those timelines
so those people would not die when maybe
those people were supposed to but we
hear strange say it was the only way
which recalls when he told tony stark
after the snap in infinity war there was
no other way so the bill coming due for
strange may also have been his inspiring
tony stark that there was one path to
victory over thanos that allowed tony to
kill thanos in in-game but that path
also needed the avengers and loki to
meddle with the time stream and in doing
so perhaps breaking various absolute
points in time that were faded really
folks being able to find and decode all
this stuff for you is such a great
holiday gift for me but if you want to
give a great holiday gift to someone
else that's gonna blow them away give
them a gift of a title from established
titles while referring to them as a lord
or lady established titles is a project
based on a historic scottish custom
where landowners are referred to as
lairds or lords and ladies in english
they let people buy as little as one
square foot of dedicated land so that
they can call themselves a lord or lady
and in return established titles commits
to planting a tree it's a really fun way
to help preserve the beautiful woodlands
and biodiversity of scotland while
raising funds to support global
conservation efforts established titles
works with global charity trees for the
future and one tree planted to help them
plant a tree for every order plus for
those with scottish heritage it's a
great way to connect to your family
roots so here's the title your title
packs give you a numbered plot of
dedicated land on a private estate in
ardele aberdeenshire scotland and an
official certificate with a crest with
this certificate you could officially
change your name to lord or lady and get
it on a credit card or plane ticket at
this point we're only a few days away
from christmas and if you still don't
have your gift ready or if it's stuck in
transit established titles is the
perfect option they are running a
holiday sale right now and you can use
our code nrs10 to get an additional 10
off so go to establishtitles.com
nrs10 to get your gifts now but then
stranger descends the sanctum stairs as
you can see stormy seawater flooding the
floor and his voice ever says i never
meant for any of this to happen then a
shot of wanda maximoff with an orb of
red chaos magic in her hand then we see
christine palmer on her wedding day
walking down the aisle as strange
watches from the pews with
dr nick west steve should be on the
altar strange and christine left things
platonically in the 2016 film but the
what if episode cast them as doomed
star-crossed lovers perhaps christine
met someone new during the blip and
strange now feels like the right one got
away then a scary crow
followed by a woman in a star jacket
this is america chavez aka miss america
played by zochi gomez she comes from the
utopian parallel she's a badass who
kicks portals through dimensions as
she's looking for her moms that are
basically disintegrated particles that
are part of the multiverse now then we
see wong looking bloody and wounded
followed by a shot of strange screaming
falling through a prison-made portal but
then we pivot as we glide across an
estate that's covered with an orchard of
white blossoming trees i want to say
dogwoods not a florist though wanda is
there trimming the flowers and she tells
strange i made mistakes and people were
but strange cuts are off i'm not here to
talk about west view then she says what
are you here for he says we need your
help with what what do you know about
the multiverse when we last saw juana
maximoff she was leaving westview behind
in the one division final episode having
dropped her hex that trapped wesley's
residence under her sitcom inspired
brainwash leaving all of them pissed off
so this newly empowered scarlet witch
exiled herself in a remote mountain
cabin where she used astral projection
to search the dark hole for a reality
where her children still exist and in
this moment we heard the doctor strange
theme music as wanda heard her kids
crying out for her
[Music]
so yes this clarifies that strange does
know about westview and remember the one
division producer said that a doctor
strange cameo was at least planned for
the show and that the commercials we saw
in each episode were intended to be
messages from dr strange thus the ask
your doctor reference but this estate
looks far away from that mountain cabin
maybe wanda is moving place to place or
given the order and perfection of those
trees and strange's curious reaction of
the setting maybe this is another pocket
reality of wanda's creation one where
she can truly be alone then we see a
hatch opening like a hatch that you'd
see on a ship but it opens to this
fantastical setting that strange looks
out upon from a chunk of brick wall
behind him are wanda and america chavez
this setting might actually be the
utopian parallel where america comes
from then we see mordo his hair grown
out in dreadlocks and he tells strange
i'm sorry steven i hope you understand
and karma taj gets overtaken with a
foreboding cloud darkness descends upon
strange and wong it's not clear how much
of a villain mordo will be in the story
he is traditionally an antagonist to
doctor strange and we know he disagrees
with their philosophy about easy magic
but i doubt he will be the ultimate
villain of the story then we see the
scarlet witch hosting a seance and a
ring of candles floating in her true
scarlet witch outfit that she made for
herself after powering up absorbing
agatha harkness's power in wandavision
we don't know exactly what wanda's role
will be in the story if she may end up
being a kind of villain but we are
keeping an eye out for any parallels
with the house of m storyline which is
the big scarlet witch storyline in the
comics where she resets reality
chaotically trying to find a reality
where her children exist and the
storyline ends with her declaring no
more mutants erasing a lot of mutants
from reality and we think in the mcu we
may see a kind of reversal of that where
she says something like let there be
mutants and mutants now exist in this
reality so she can have her brother and
her kids back strange and mordo dual
explosions tear through the camaratage
courtyard wong rises to his feet and
then strange conjures an array of red
orbs from the sanctum floor these look a
lot like the orbs that wanda conjured in
the one division post credits scene and
with those tethers connecting them all
this may be a depiction of
interconnected worlds in the multiverse
then strange faces this huge tentacled
monster in the street many of us believe
that we'd be seeing schuma gorath in
this movie but this is actually the sea
monster of gargantos according to leaks
of lego sets gargantos is an old school
namor villain and he may have actually
come in with that flooding water through
the sanctum floor it just sounds like
this is gonna be a big monster movie and
doctor strange is gonna have to deal
with a lot of interdimensional beasts
gargantus throws a busted strange with
an ad for a cafe la llave espresso
unlock a better day maybe the joke being
that this threat the strange is just
something he has to face for breakfast
every day he uses a spell to slice the
bus in half protecting himself in
america chavez hope no one was on that
bus you just pulled a cersei my friend
and then as mordo says the greatest
threat to our universe is you strange
finds himself in this alternate sanctum
sick gothic decor harp piano that's my
man cave all looks out in a swirling
cloud strange meets an alternate version
of himself a darker sexier variant who
smiles and says things just got out of
hand now my first assumption was that
this could be strange supreme whom we
last saw in the what-if finale locked in
a pocket dimension overseeing an inner
pocket dimension at the behest of the
watcher to keep killmonger infinity in
zola ultron locked in an eternal tug of
war over the infinity stones but i'm not
sure this is strange supreme just
because this guy's got a different abode
he seems far more devilish than strange
supreme ended up being strange supreme
was just more driven by love and
desperation for power to break an
absolute point but for love this guy
seems more evil but also notice the
other strange specifically his eye bully
mcguire just put some dirt in that eye a
purple color so this might not actually
be the same variant we started with we
could be seeing a lot of doctor
strange's this one could be imbued with
power from the dark dimension the same
kind of magic agatha harkness might have
been channeling ultimately i think what
this tells us is that multiverse of
madness is gonna be a story with a ton
of doctor strange's similar to what we
saw in loki which is really a show about
the various loki variants doctor strange
could end up having to face his many
alternate selves each of whom were born
out of the times he violated fate in the
2016 doctor strange infinity war an
in-game in a no way home there could be
as many as 14
605 doctor strange's he has to deal with
except each of these variants are all
master sorcerers who can each change the
fabric of reality in their own way so
that could be why doctor strange needs
these other nexus beans the scarlet
witch america chavez and who knows maybe
loki and sylvie too all of these
sorcerers to help pay the bill that has
now come due my full scene by scene
breakdown of all the easter eggs you
missed in spider-man no way home is
coming tomorrow followed by several days
of videos about other questions you
might have had about this film so to
support our channel check out one of our
great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything marvel
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you